we are continuing our special eye on
earth
our planet in peril series on this earth
day april 22nd
much of the electricity that powers the
u.s still comes from burning coal
generating that power accounts for 25
percent of our greenhouse gas emissions
that are warming the planet the biden
administration wants to bring that
number to net
zero by 2035 by shifting to more
renewable energy
but a recent cbs news poll found that 46
percent of americans think well that
goal is
unrealistic our senior environmental
correspondent that's been tracy
joins us from sparrows point maryland to
show us
one source of renewable energy that the
administration is really counting on
ben good morning to you gail good
morning so we're talking about offshore
wind and that is exactly what it sounds
like you build
giant wind turbines offshore way out
there in the ocean now
this is part of baltimore harbor and the
hope is that this is going to become
part of a hub that is going to support a
massive expansion
of the offshore wind industry in the u.s
which right now
is pretty darn small
the blades on these 300 foot tall wind
turbines gently bow in the breeze
as if part of some elaborate industrial
ballet
there are just seven operating offshore
wind turbines in u.s
waters these are five of them basically
this is offshore wind in this country
right now
yeah you could say that david hardy is
the north american ceo
of orsted a wind powered giant based in
denmark
he took us out on the bright blue waters
off the coast of rhode island
to see the first and still largest
offshore wind farm
in the united states it is cool to see
it up close
hardy says the u.s is way behind europe
where large offshore wind farms have
been used for decades
europe's offshore wind farms produce
nearly 25 000 megawatts of power
china's about 10 000 megawatts here in
the u.s
we produce 42. 42
42 so not 4 200 not 42 000
42 flats so we've got it we've got a
ways to go to catch up
the biden administration wants offshore
wind in u.s waters to produce
30 thousand megawatts of power by 2030
enough to supply more than 10 million
homes so how many homes in the u.s can
be powered by offshore wind right now
well this wind farm powers about 17
000 homes here in rhode island and all
of them
are here on block island which was
powered entirely by
diesel fuel until 2016 when those big
white blades started spinning
off its shores used to burn a million
gallons a year
sven resume lives on the island and is
one of the very few americans whose
power comes from offshore wind
doesn't get much better we're capturing
wind that we have here
all the time the biden administration
plans to speed up permitting for new
projects in federal waters
mostly along the eastern seaboard an
ideal setting thanks to a combination of
strong steady wind shallow water which
makes installing the towers easier
and dense population centers that need
power this is one of the best areas in
the world some have to update the saudi
arabia of offshore wind
the saudi arabia of offshore wind i
hadn't heard that one
lars peterson is ceo of vineyard wind
which plans to install
62 of these giant ge wind turbines by
2023
about 15 miles off martha's vineyard the
wind farm would provide
clean electricity to more than 400 000
homes and businesses
in massachusetts the blades are more
than 300 feet long so
longer than a football field every two
spins of the blades you can power home
for one day
so it's really really impressive
hardware but not
everyone is impressed some coastal
homeowners have complained the turbines
will ruin their views
and fishermen are concerned about access
to fishing grounds
and navigating around the giant towers
but the white house is moving ahead
claiming the offshore wind industry will
employ more than 44 thousand americans
by 2030. this has already transformed
our business
tierra strum owns a welding company in
baltimore
her company was hired to work on this
massive port facility in maryland
built to service the future offshore
wind industry what did that project mean
for your company
it allowed us to purchase this 20 000
square foot facility
and it allowed us to create eight
full-time jobs
so this was real money this was real
money and she's hoping more of it will
blow her way
now that those five turbines are about
to get a lot of new neighbors
most of these wind turbines that are
going to be built will be built so far
out you'll hardly be able to see them
from shore
and while it is still an open question
if they really will be able to create
44 000 new jobs in this industry as the
biden administration is promising
there's no doubt this is a huge
opportunity for the u.s when it comes to
renewable energy
anthony i know a lot of people think of
those as eyesores but i actually find
them really beautiful i do
too i do too and then when they show the
shot of blocking the view
thinking that what kind of view is it
blocking exactly they're like giant
works of art really
that's the way i feel and and the job
creation is also impressive at that
welding company
in maryland so coal jobs may go away to
some extent but if there's an off-road
for those people to retrain there are
other jobs that will
pop up i like what how ben said he hopes
more business blows tierra's way i
thought yeah
we're pulling for tierra in her business
our thanks to ben tracy